und jetzt kommen wir zu unserem cold
case morgen am mittwoch der hätte
postboten heidi dannhäuser aus nürnberg
ihren 58 geburtstag gefeiert doch seit
dem 14 november 2013 fehlt von heidi
jede spur vor ein paar jahren da steht
der fall dann auf einmal kurz vor dem
durchbruch die polizei die nimmt den
lebensgefährten ins visier und wie es
dann weiterging erzählt unser reporter
jörg völkerling heidi dannhäuser
49 jahre alt von beruf postboten jeder
kennt sie jeder mag sie sie ist
zuverlässig immer pünktlich
in ihrer freizeit ist sie sehr aktiv
heidi joggt gerne in einem nahe
gelegenen wald oder macht touren mit
ihrem motorrad
sie lebt und arbeitet im nürnberger
stadtteil fischbach mit ihrem
lebensgefährten freddy hat sie dort ein
haus gekauft und in diesem haus wird
heidi zum letzten mal gesehen in der
nacht vom 13 auf den 14 november 2013
verliert sich ihre spur
heidi dannhäuser gilt seitdem als
vermisst die ermittler gehen von einem
verbrechen aus
[Musik]
egal was da vorgefallen ist gut da
draußen das hat sie nicht verdient und
auch nicht darum wollen wir nicht locker
lassen wir wollen nicht aufgeben weil
ich finde wir haben keine ruhe und
derjenige oder diejenigen die damit zu
tun haben welche das angetan worden ist
sie sollen auch keine ruhe
[Musik]
stefanie und petra sind heidi schwestern
und sehr eng miteinander
sie können immer noch nicht glauben dass
heidi einfach so verschwunden ist
unermüdlich suchen sie nach ihrer
schwester heidi bis heute seit jahren
haben sie nur einen wunsch dass heidi
vielleicht doch noch liebt
heide wenn du irgendwo ist kommen
einfach zurück oder gibt ein
lebenszeichen
bild reporter jörg völkerling trifft die
schwestern in fischbach genau dort wo
heidi zum letzten mal gesehen wurde ihr
schicksal bewegt auch den gestandenen
reporter
wie kann es sein dass eine so patente
unbekannte frau wie heidi dannhäuser
einfach aus dem nürnberger stadtteil
fischbach verschwindet
oder die postbotin opfer eines
verbrechens was ist mit heidi dannhäuser
geschenk sich spüren ist die
kriminalpolizei in nürnberg im fall
heidi dannhäuser nachgegangen die
ermittler geben nicht auf und hoffen
noch auf den entscheidenden hinweis
der fall hat mich schon immer bewegt
weil ich eben auch von anfang an dabei
war
ich werde solange ich hier in dieser
dienststelle diesen job macht an diesem
fall dranbleiben das kann ich versichern
weil ich mir das auch als lebensaufgabe
geschrieben habe diesen fall zu klären
wo ist heidi dannhäuser der fall der
beliebten postbotin bewegt viele
menschen die stadtreklame in nürnberg
hängt unentgeltlich immer wieder ein
riesiges werbeplakat an der ein und
ausfallstraße nach fischbach auf heidi
dannhäuser hat hier in der nähe gewohnt
und vielleicht erinnert sich noch jemand
sie am 14 november 2013 butter danach
gesehen zu haben auch bild reporter jörg
völkerling und seine kollegen begleiten
den fall seit jahren
vermisst polizei sucht diese frau
taucher suchen postbotin im weiher
heidi verschwand durch die terrassentür
kost boten opfer eines verbrechens
polizeipräsidium nürnberg seit acht
jahren laufen hier die fäden zum fall
heidi dannhäuser zusammen bild reporter
jörg völkerling ist mit
kriminalhauptkommissar thomas ringer
verabredet
wir sind ja sehr lange in der ganzen
materie schon seit dem ersten tag
und das sind nur die spurenakten in dem
fall das sind die spuren nachgegangen
130 bürger unter 30 sind geworden ja
aber leider bis jetzt kein ergebnis
es gab keine antworten gegenüber
wichtigen bezugspersonen also sie hatten
ja wirklich sehr guten kontakt zu ihren
schwestern und da hat sie überhaupt
nichts durchklingen lassen dass sie das
lebens hat hat dass sie keine lust mehr
hat auf zu hause und dass sie weg muss
[Musik]
was ist mit heidi dannhäuser geschehen
den abend des 13 11 20 13 10 konnte die
polizei anhand der aussagen des
lebensgefährten rekonstruieren freddy
will sich mit seinem pc beschäftigt
haben nach der arbeit kommt heidi nach
hause in die kellergasse in fischbach
die beiden unterhalten sich lautstark es
gibt meinungsverschiedenheiten
so berichten nachbarn heidi legt sich
aufs sofa freddy setzt sich wieder an
den computer erst spät in der nacht geht
er ins bett am nächsten morgen
donnerstag der vierzehnte elfte 2013 ist
heidi verschwunden so schildert ihr
lebensgefährte die letzten stunden er
hat sich auch erstmal nicht mehr so viel
geht an gemacht sondern sich um seine
sachen gekümmert und ist dann aber schon
nervös geworden und hat im wald auf
eigene faust nach ihr gesucht am 15 11
2013 hat er sich dann dazu bewegt
gefühlt anzeige zu erstatten weil sie
dann bis dahin auch nicht aufgetaucht
ist und auch ihre arbeitsstelle nicht
wahrgenommen hat die sonst sehr
zuverlässig antritt sie waren den
zeitpunkt noch mit freddie zusammen aber
da hat es gekriselt hat es mich immer
anrufen und hat ihre kummer und ihre
sorgen erzählen aber immer wenn er
natürlich nicht da war das hat ja immer
heimlich gemacht
[Musik]
unmittelbar nachdem der
vermisstenanzeige
gehen die ersten maßnahmen
die eine streife fährt dann unmittelbar
zum wohnanwesen und schaut da nach
ersten spuren bzw hinweisen die darauf
hindeuten wo sie hingegangen ist oder
was passiert ist bei ihr war eben
ausschlag geben dass sie ihre
arbeitsstelle nicht wahrgenommen hat das
war ein entscheidendes kriterium
kriterium zu sagen hier ist irgendwas im
arbeiten am liebsten isst mal zuhause
nachzuschauen was hat sie denn
hinterlassen was ist noch da was deutet
darauf hin wo sie hingegangen ist in
diesem fall stand auch zum beispiel noch
ihr auto vor der tür das ist
ungewöhnlich ihr neuer roter golf auf
den sie so sehr stolz ist im
schlafzimmer fehlt nichts und ihre
handtasche ist auch noch da darin all
ihre persönlichen sachen
personalausweis hausschlüssel
mobiltelefon
heidis schwester petra und stefanie
kommen sofort nach fischbach und hängen
zettel auf die damals 49 jährige heidi
zeigen und beschreiben
seit dem 14 11 20 01 13 vormittags wird
frau heidi dannhäuser vermisst sie ist 1
meter 64 groß hat blonde schulterlange
haare
heidi geht fast täglich joggen ist ihr
im wald etwas passiert das wohnhaus
befindet sich in fischbach einem
ortsteil von nürnberg der lorenzer
reichswald ist ganz nah dort befindet
sich auch der eisweiher hatte heidi beim
laufen einen unfall ist sie unglücklich
in den weiher gestürzt oder wurde dort
ihr leichnam versteckt ermittler
befragen den lebensgefährten und alle
nachbarn während die
bereitschaftspolizei den nahe gelegenen
wald ab sucht ein spürhund hat dort
heidi dannhäuser vierter aufgenommen
[Musik]
taucher steigen an diesem kalten
novembertag sogar in den ice bayer
doch alle bemühungen führen ins leere
heidi dannhäuser bleibt verschwunden
auch nach drei tagen gibt es kein
lebenszeichen von ihr
13 da hatte ich einen anruf von der
heidi ich war in der arbeit ich habe den
anruf gesehen also das ist das was mich
was mich auch noch heute beschäftigt das
er nicht ran gegangen bin aber nimmt man
wahr mein geschäft und ich konnte nicht
rangehen und ich habe mir gedacht ich
bin sowieso in einer viertel stunde
fertig und dann rufe ich sie gleich
zurück nach der singstunde ich bin ins
auto und habe sie auch sofort angerufen
aber
da kam die meldung
und dann kam aber kurz danach eine eine
whatsapp ich rufe dich morgen an das
wäre dann der 14
ein anruf der niemals kommt seit der
nacht zum 14 november 2013 verliert sich
die spur zu heidi dannhäuser die polizei
sucht im nahen umfeld von heidi nach
gründen für ihr verschwinden hat ihr
lebensgefährte freddy etwas damit zu tun
ist heidi vielleicht untergetaucht um
ein neues leben ganz woanders zu
beginnen
das einzige was bekannt wurde das ist
und da haben wir auch lange betreiben
ermittelt dass sie kurz vorher im urlaub
in spanien war und dieser urlaub was sie
für sie das größte in der letzten zeit
das größte erlebnis in der letzten zeit
und sie hat sich auch zu ihrem
anstehenden 50 fünfzigsten geburtstag am
24 11 2013
unbedingt geld beziehungsweise
gutscheine gewünscht um die sich diesen
urlaub nach spanien wieder leisten zu
können am 25
heften will heidi ihren geburtstag
feiern im keller finden die beamten
zwischen lehrern sprudel und bierkästen
reichlich neu gekauften alkohol wein und
schnaps für eine party für die polizei
ein indiz dass sie es nicht mit einem
selbstmord zu tun hat doch wo ist heidi
ist sie vielleicht in ihrem traumland
spanien untergetaucht auch dafür gibt es
hinweise
[Musik]
wo ist heidi dannhäuser seit der nacht
zum 14 november 2013 wird die damals 49
jährige vermisst in dieser nacht haben
nachbarn in der kellergasse in nürnberg
fischbach einen streit gehört am
nächsten morgen ist heidi nicht mehr da
ihr lebensgefährte erstattet nach 24
stunden eine vermisstenmeldung
ist heidi dannhäuser auf ihrer
joggingstrecke im nahen wald etwas
passiert
die polizei sucht das areal ab findet
keine spur
ihre schwestern suchen mit selbst
gedruckten plakate nach hier
[Musik]
im wohnhaus findet die polizei heidis
papiere ihr geld und ihr handy auch ihr
neuer wagen steht noch vor der tür einen
abschiedsbrief gibt es nicht die polizei
schließt einen selbstmord aus wurde
heidi getötet
die indizien deuten eher darauf hin dass
sie nicht mehr am leben ist aber dann
würde ich gern haben dass sich dadurch
sicherheit habe und dass man sagt ja
wohl jetzt haben wir sie gefunden jetzt
als wissen wir was ist
2018 kommt wieder bewegung in den fall
das haus wird zwangsversteigert
denn sei dies verschwinden würden ihre
raten nicht mehr bezahlt schulden sind
aufgelaufen
mit der versteigerung des hauses haben
sich hier zusätzliche indizien aber
wirklich nur indizien ergeben die ein
verdacht aufkommen lassen dass die
leiche daher dannhäuser irgendwo auf dem
grundstück in dem haus versteckt ist um
welche indizien also beweisanzeichen es
sich handelt sagt thomas renger aus
ermittlungstaktischen gründen nicht
welchen status hat der lebensgefährte
bei ihren ermittlungen zu diesem
zeitpunkt habe er beschuldigte gegen
freddy wurde damals strafrechtlich wegen
totschlags ermittelt
wir hatten der lebensgefährte darauf
reagiert als sie an diesem morgen sehr
früh wahrscheinlich mit dem
durchsuchungsbeschluss in der hand bei
ihm auf der matte standen der
lebensgefährte hat hat das akzeptiert
mit beschluss aber er war natürlich
maximal überrascht ja ganz klar es war
ja auch nicht nur so dass sie zwei leute
an der tür geklingelt haben sondern da
kann man ja drei lkws mit material
im mai 2018 rückt die polizei mit einem
großaufgebot hier in der kellergasse an
die ganze straße wird für den
durchgangsverkehr gesperrt gerade mal
der bus darf noch passieren drei tage
sind die ermittler im haus und stellen
es komplett auf den kopf überall wird
gründlich nachgeschaut mit
spezialgeräten nach hohlräumen geforscht
bei der suche nach skelettierten knochen
helfen speziell ausgebildete knochen
spürhunde die spezialisten rücken
erfolglos ab freddy kann nichts
nachgewiesen werden die ermittlungen
wegen totschlags werden eingestellt der
fall zum court case heidis
lebensgefährte lebt heute als
frührentner nur 50 kilometer entfernt es
gibt im moment keine hinweise keine
spuren mehr die noch offen sind die zu
ermitteln wäre aber wir sehen lag das
auch an ihnen dass das so ein fall
sozusagen so loch sich auftut und jemand
darin verschwindet und das nicht klar
ist nicht greifbar ist für sie wie sehr
macht ihnen das zu schaffen also der
fall die dann häuser ist wirklich ein
fall der mir sehr zu schaffen macht und
ich werde solange ich hier in dieser
dienststelle diesen job macht an diesem
fall dranbleiben das kann ich versichern
weil ich mir das auch als lebensaufgabe
geschrieben habe diesen fall zu klären
ich bitte sie wenn sie irgendwelche
feststellungen gemacht haben die zum
auffinden der heidi dannhäuser führen
wenden sie sich an eine
polizeidienststelle umgeben sie das von
sich aus bekannt oder wer weiß über
folgenden sachverhalt etwas beim
ausräumen des hauses findet sich eine
notiz costa del sol und kann in heidis
handschrift vor ihrem verschwinden war
heidi in spanien schwer und von einem
leben an spanien südküste wünscht sich
geld zum geburtstag für eine neuerliche
reise dorthin ist heidi dort
untergetaucht für die schwestern kaum
vorstellbar
sie hätte jederzeit sagen
ich halte es nicht mehr aus ich vom
spanien schön
und ich habe da so eine idee ich
probiere das jetzt aus und gehe einfach
dass das jetzt jeder zeit machen können
die kripo geht auch der spur nach
spanien nach bislang ohne ergebnis
unter den notizen finden die schwestern
auch den namen eines plastischen
chirurgen wollte heidi ihr aussehen
verändern wer weiß etwas darüber
sogar den termin gemacht für eine
korrektur
denen sie dann nicht mehr angetreten
nicht mehr antreten konnte sie wollte
sich verändern was jetzt auch ihr ganzes
leben sie verändert sieht verändern
wollte oder sie selber zu ändern wollte
das weiß man im nachhinein nicht
petra und stefanie wünschen sich dass
heidis verschwinden aufgeklärt wird dass
ihre schwester doch noch lebt
[Musik]
heide wenn du irgendwo bis wir vermissen
dich so so sehr wenn du irgendwo bis
gibt es ein lebenszeichen
wir drücken
informationen und hinweise die zur
klärung des vermisstenfalls der heidi
tannhäuser führen können nimmt die
polizei in nürnberg oder jede andere
polizeidienststelle entgegen
und heidis familie hat dafür eine
belohnung von 8000 euro ausgesetzt
ja seit acht jahren hoffen die
schwestern darauf endlich zu erfahren
was mit ihrer heidi geschehen ist wenn
sie doch noch etwas wissen was das leid
der familie endlich beenden kann dann
melden sie sich bei der polizei unter
2112 3333